[Musique]
j'ai tout le temps a dit un jour je veux
écrire des livres c'est de prendre le
pain oxydes s'arrêter là c'est sa vision
mais comme ministre vous avez l'un des
plus grands pour te vois qu'ils soient
s'était pas encore assez on gère
beaucoup le quotidien rarement on a la
chance de dire aux gens moi je pense que
l'alphabétisation
ça dépend des statistiques bon faut dire
que dans le présent mandat depuis avril
il ya d'autres députés qui ont écrit un
livre mais eux ils sont encore nos
positions
[Musique]
les titres québécois sciences humaines
et sociales se vendait en moyenne à un
peu moins de 900 exemplaires soit roll
succès que ça avance au tirage que ça va
ça laisse une trace
certains vont dire que c'est une façon
de vous positionner dans l'espace public
si jamais un jour vous êtes prétendants
à la direction du parti libéral bien
fondé ou pas fondé première chose qui
s'est dit il fait sur pour d'autres
raisons que celles que je viens
d'évoquer
ça se passait très zen je le fais pas
pour ça je le fais pour positionner
développe une réflexion dans la société
d'abord pourquoi est ce que le ministère
un problème de crédibilité jeudi dans
livres qu'il ya des enjeux de
crédibilité c'est vrai pour toutes les
grandes organisations publiques
le ministère a été créé pour être
l'instrument des gens pour créer système
d'éducation au fil du temps il est
devenu quelqu'un en charge de la
réglementation et je pense pas que le
ministère doit belize et ceux et celles
qui veulent changer les choses à plat
sur les enseignants vous évoquez des
choses vous dites des choses sans le
dire vraiment est ce que vous voulez un
autre professionnel oui je pense qu' il
faudra y venir
c'est une occasion pour les enseignants
se réapproprier la profession est-ce
qu'il faut qu'ils aient une maîtrise ou
non juste une bonne question ça ça fait
partie des propositions qui sont sur la
table
la formation d'aujourd'hui académique
n'est pas le reflet de ce qui se passe
dans les classes et pour conduire les
gens secret jusqu'à la maîtrise faut
qu'un bénéfice ce bout de deux heures
puis ça prend un bon sens là parce que
c'est un emploi qui est pas comme les
autres je dis dans le livre parce qu'ils
méritent des conditions autres à terme
mais il faut respecter cette capacité de
pays pour voir comment ce qu'on peut
enclencher ce processus
vous devez djalloul des tambourettes
autant c'est parce qu'on peut se
comparer les affaires
semblait viser les syndicats je vis pas
les syndicats principalement ils ont un
rôle à jouer mais ils doivent s'inscrire
dans une démarche d'amélioration font
juste aussi reconnaître que les temps
aux gens